c'est un concert unique pour un site qui
l'est tout autant dans cinq jours le
chanteur sting va se produire sur les
pelouses du château de chambord alors
que vingt mille personnes assisteront à
cet événement en coulisses un générateur
solaire éphémère vient d'être installé
pour compenser les émissions de carbone
générées par cette soirée gourmande en
énergie
plus d'explications dans ce reportage de
samuel colin
150 panneaux solaires déployés en une
vingtaine de minutes c'est la promesse
de ce générateur photovoltaïque
produire de l'énergie immédiatement dans
ce container l'onduleur transforme le
courant continu en alternatif
j'ai remonté et de
publicité toutes les utilisations du
festival un test grandeur réelle pour
l'entreprise roy l'objectif analyser la
quantité de kilowattheures produite par
la centrale et convaincre de se passer
des générateurs thermiques ça va être la
première vraie expérimentation de
déploiement sur une zone qui en a besoin
donc l'idée de prouver que le générateur
photovoltaïque qui est derrière moi va
générer au moins deux fois l'énergie que
le concert devrait consommer pendant les
quatre ou cinq heures de production
l'installation n'a donc pas vocation à
produire de l'énergie pour le concert de
sting mais convaincre de sa pertinence
200 litres de pétrole contre cinq jours
de soleil au coût actuel du diesel le
soler redevient compétitif il y avait la
volonté des deux parts de la part des
deux protêts là par le roi énergie daley
pour aux énergies vers le concert nous
vers quelque chose de plus de plus
durable et donc on est tous intéressés à
pouvoir sur le long terme développer
un concert comme celui ci demande de dix
à douze mille kilowattheure pour les
cinq heures de spectacle
l'équivalent en énergie solaire sera
bien injecter le lendemain dans le
réseau électrique de chambord ces
centrales photovoltaïques pourront être
à terme utilisé pour de l'événementiel
mais aussi sur des zones sinistrées où
des terrains de guerre